I'm gonna try to make this talk a little
bit light a little bit less technical
just so that we know it's the end of the
conference and everything and hopefully
there'll be fun pictures and stuff to
close the conference on okay I'm going
to be talking about detecting bugs and
explaining predictions of machine
learning models but before I do that
let's actually talk about what you can
do with machine learning so suppose
you're walking outside and you see this
creature it's kind of not very clear but
suppose you see it lying on the road and
you find it to be really cute and you
want to take it home and you want to
adopt it the question is well is this
something you should do you can easily
be like okay can machine learning help
me turns out it can you can go online
find a bunch of photos of wolves find a
bunch of photos of husky which is a very
similar breed that often looks like this
and then you train your machine learning
system it takes couple of hours maybe or
maybe even less than that and then a
machine learning model could tell you
that hey this is actually a wolf you
should not take it home and in fact if
you look at a different animal like this
you might be like okay this is a husky
and you can take it home right and then
this can sort of be trained in a matter
of a couple of hours and in fact here
are some held out data that we showed
the classifier and out of these six
animals which I can't quite tell Huskies
involves apart only it made only one
mistake so this model is already better
than one human arguably better than many
many humans in a matter of couple of
hours that's great but that's a very toy
a problem that we created in a couple of
hours what's the state of the art like
in terms of classification we can also
do a lot with text this is where a lot
of my research is this is an example of
an email you don't have to read the
whole thing but if you skim it you're
going to get the gist that this email is
probably not pro Christianity it's
probably Pro atheism so if you had to
classify it between an atheistic text or
a Christian text you can probably guess
it's atheism and turns out machine
learning
models right now can also do a pretty
good job of predicting that it's easiest
and that's kind of impressive because
you kind of have to understand the text
atheism doesn't really appear anywhere
here there is nothing here that's
directly like hate sentiment against God
or anything like that you kind of have
to understand what the the person is
actually writing about here's another
example which is called visual question
answering this is coming close to sort
of state of the art machine learning
maybe two or three years maybe four
years old
well you're given an image which could
be a pretty strange image like like you
see here and instead of just classifying
it or anything like that you can ask an
arbitrary question off of that image so
you can say is there a mustache in this
picture and even though the machine
learning model has never seen anything
like this it's somehow understand that
there is a conceptual notion of a
mustache here and answers yes and it's
not just a yes-or-no that's like a
binary classification problem you can
even ask it arbitrary questions like
what is the mustache made of and again
it has never seen a mustache made up of
bananas it has never seen a mustache on
a woman
it says banana seems to understand the
question seems to understand the images
and seems to do pretty well on these
data sets not quite as good as humans
but in some cases coming pretty close
that was sort of a useless example you
usually don't see women walking around
with bananas talk to their faces but you
might actually see a road sign in a
foreign country and you might not know
what it is and so these kind of systems
are trained to be able to you know work
in these contexts as well you can ask
them what type of road sign is shown and
it can tell you stop it's not just doing
OCR or something like that it's just
trained and to end the same system is
answering the previous questions as is
answering this question and this
question answering is a pretty strong
format it's it's pretty expressive and
sort of encapsulate it's a bunch of
tasks so you can do question answering
not just with images you can also do it
with text all right
so suppose someone gives you this text
that looks pretty boring to read you
don't want to read it but you still are
interests
in figuring out how long is the river
called Rhine without reading there are
existing machine learning algorithms
that can find the relevant pieces put
them together and you will see that in
order to answer this question you can I
have to read multiple sentences put it
together and give the answer twelve
hundred and thirty kilometers sorry the
colors are a bit faded so that's great
like these models seem to be doing
really really well they're able to
differentiate between volts and husky's
they're able to read text and figure out
whether it's about Christianity or not
they're able to answer questions about
images answer questions about pieces of
text and for this one specifically it
was the latest systems are better than
humans in terms of accuracy but the
question that we often ask or we should
be asking is whether machine learning is
actually doing what we want right so
let's see what these machine learning
algorithms look like here's a neural
network where each line here is a weight
and so they're already thousands of
maybe hundreds of weights in this case
and each weight is some number and
there's no idea how that number
corresponds to what you're trying to
predict three is it doing what we want I
don't know one of the edges says minus
ten other one says 2.45 whatever right
this dual network is actually at this
point maybe fifteen years old
the latest one looked like this which I
can't fit vertically I have to make
horizontal because they're so deep where
each of these blue boxes or red boxes is
more complicated than the one I showed
you and so we are talking about millions
of numbers here no idea why it's doing
what it's doing and in fact this is also
at this point maybe three or four years
old
the latest neural networks are
equivalent to a thousand layer so there
are hundreds of million parameters there
are some in NLP that are hitting a
billion parameters as well so a billion
numbers you figure out what it's doing
that's not great and so one of the
questions that is natural to ask is is
it anywhere close to what humans are
doing if you're comparing against humans
in terms of accuracy is it actually
doing what it should be doing so the
problem is that it
initially because of this complication
there black boxes
what that means is we don't really know
what's happening inside it and so we
don't know whether we can trust the
predictions or not we don't know what
kind of mistakes they would make are
they stupid mistakes or are there more
reasonable mistakes which is a big big
problem if you're trying to deploy these
systems you don't know what kind of
behavior to expect if it's unleashed
onto the public you can't predict what's
gonna happen you know some accuracy
metric but you don't know how well that
corresponds to what's gonna happen and
essentially as developers we also don't
know how to debug these systems like
something goes wrong okay well sometimes
we can just take the machine learning
model offline if it's too bad but it's
not easy to fix the bugs in these
machine learning systems so let's go
back to some of the examples and see is
this actually a problem or am I just
sort of you know do these things
actually exists problems with black
boxes when we go back to this simple
classifier that I had created I told you
that you know it seems to be doing a
reasonably good job of separating holes
and Huskies and essentially it was
making only one mistake but actually
when we look closer as to what was going
on it was essentially a snow detector
what that means is every time it saw
snow in the image can it didn't matter
what the animal was it didn't matter
what the color of the animal was how
sharp the teeth were or whatever if it
saw snow it predicted it was wolf if it
didn't see snow it predicted it was
husky you can see this error makes sense
now this happens to be a husky in a
snowy environment and the model gets it
wrong but in terms of accuracy it turns
out to be a pretty good pretty accurate
system on this data set now the question
is well if you take such a system that
only relies on snow and is ignoring the
animal and you deploy it in the real
world you will see news articles like
these this wasn't using a machine
learning system this is even without a
machine learning system people make
mistakes so putting machine learning
just blindly is now
let's go back to this example where we
read this text and we were pretty
convinced this looked like it ism and
the model gets it right we were just
playing around with this model and we
looked at a different example the one
that it gets it wrong and turns out this
is the example I don't know if everybody
can read so I'll read it out there's a
header there and then it says I think
Christianity is the one true religion if
you'd like to know more send me a knot
now the question is is this about it is
amol Christianity I think everybody will
agree that this is about Christianity
but the model thinks it's about atheism
and not only does it think it's a little
bit about atheism it's actually pretty
confident it's 80% confident that this
is about atheism and suddenly that this
makes us question what the models
actually doing because we were convinced
that it was able to read in some sense
and figure out the first one was atheism
but even for such a simple such a
blatant example it seems to be getting
it wrong and in fact if we are the
developer of this model and we see this
we have no idea why this happened we
have no idea what to do next what do how
to fix it and just to let you know this
is not a bad model this is actually 94%
accuracy held out cross validation
whatever it is it's one of the most
accurate models on this data set it just
so happens that one of the 6% errors
it's making or many of the 6% errors
it's making look very simple like this
okay let's keep going so we saw this
example what is the most - made off it
said banana we said just playing around
with this model what are the eyes made
of and it said bananas that sort of made
us pause because we thought it was doing
reading and looking at images and things
like that
clearly not so we asked it what is said
banana we said what it's a banana
it seems somehow it figures out for the
first question that banana is the right
response but for a bunch of questions it
just gives banana as a response and
again we couldn't have foreseen this was
happening and even now that we know this
is happening it's not clear how to fix
it onto a more realistic example we saw
this question what type of road sign is
shown it says stop we just rephrase the
question to make it which type of road
sign is shown it's the same question
we've just replaced water with which and
the answer changes it becomes do not
enter which means very something very
different from a stop sign which would
of course if you're using it in the real
world you would have to know how to
phrase the question and not say which
type of road sign is shown because
someone would tell you that that's the
wrong thing but right now we don't even
know that this problem exists in machine
learning models and as our final example
we were talking about this text case how
long is the Rhine we took the same
question how long is the Rhine and we
added an extra question mark at the end
and gave it to this model which was one
of the best models at the time and it
gave a different answer it said now it's
more than a million no units but
kilometers or miles long right clearly
long clearly that's that phrase appears
in the paragraph but it has nothing to
do with the river or the length of the
river but that's what the model does and
all we've done is added an extra
question and so the point is that these
models are incredibly complicated and
they are pretty accurate they're pretty
useful I mean I'm a machine learning
researcher because I love them but they
can be brittle in ways that are
completely different from and completely
unintuitive and also in ways that are
very difficult to figure out and and
sort of test for and so my work has
mostly more recently been on how can we
actually find these bugs we have these
machine learning systems they're useful
they're being deployed everywhere how
can we actually find these bugs and
specifically how can we do this
automatic
as much as possible and so in this talk
I'm gonna talk about a few different
strategies we have and I'm gonna go
through them as quickly as I can to sort
of address this problem the first set of
methods are going to be trying to
explain predictions to figure out why a
specific prediction was made and we
essentially have two ways of approaching
how to explain the predictions and then
in the second part I'm going to talk
about using adversarial attacks as a way
to detect problems in the model so act
like an adversary and see what the
worst-case behavior of these models is
yes and we have sort of two completely
different style of approaching this
problem one is to work with meaningful
adversaries that are more natural in the
sort of what you might naturally
encounter and then towards the end I'm
gonna talk about some worst-case
adversaries where how bad can your
system be if it has these bugs okay so
let's start with the first which was
explaining predictions we just sort of
appears in these two papers um again
since this is PI data conference I want
to say that everything we do is released
open source links to the github repo are
available from my website and stuff like
that and I encourage you to try these
things out and finally shoes and stuff
like that yeah okay so let's talk about
why we even are talking about
interpretability turns out you can take
machine learning models and think about
them in two dimensions in how accurate
they are and how much do we understand
about what's happening inside and
clearly we want systems that are
accurate and interpretable so they
should be on the top right or left
depending on me or you and initially if
we go back historically the models used
to be somewhere down there you used to
be pretty interpretable there were
pretty simple linear equations like this
one don't know if you can see it but
they're only two dimensions to it or
they used to look like simple decision
trees where you can look at them and
understand okay if I have fever above
104 I'm probably going to die how
whatever it is
but the models have been getting much
more complicated which means we are
losing interpretability
and they're getting much much more
accurate so the linear models now are
often used in many cases and they tend
to be pretty complicated not quite as
interpretable if people have tried to
interpret coefficients they might might
understand that
similarly decision trees have become
random forests or really deep decision
trees and again you get these really
complicated surfaces where you have no
idea exactly what's happening
everything depends on these ten
conditions and so on and so based on
this sort of setup a lot of people
started working on interpretable models
models that were in hent inherently
interpretable but also accurate as much
as possible and there is a lot of cool
stuff that's happening and increasingly
happening in that area but for the most
part for the applications that I'm
talking about they don't quite meet the
real world utility they're not the ones
that are causing us to you know get
excited about machine learning the way
other approaches have been and so in
this scenario essentially deep learning
came together or neural networks or
whatever you want to call it where they
decided to forget about interpreter
bility and make the models as complex as
possible and essentially they climbed as
high as they can on the accuracy level
in many cases above real-world use case
in many cases close to or above human
level accuracy whatever that means for
the task and so that's kind of the
scenario where we are so what my work
has been doing is to say we are going to
try and explain why these complex models
make their decisions and we're going to
be pretty local about what we want to do
so let's see what does that mean what
that means is since these models are
really complicated if you try to plot
them out they look like really really
complicated surfaces so even if it's wow
you guys can't really see it can you see
your [ __ ] and bluish thing not really
okay well that's okay there's a
complicated curve there
that nobody can understand nobody can
even see and the point is that it's too
complicated to understand that's
basically like interpreting every number
in your model instead what you're going
to do is we're going to look at a single
prediction a single X here that was
predicted to be positive and we're going
to see where in this curve does this
point lie and essentially zoom in and
some cool animation stuff is happening
which you can't appreciate but yeah be
impressed I guess and essentially what
we're going to do is we're going to zoom
into a very local region and figure out
for this prediction what is the model to
me we're not going to care about what's
gonna happen for other instances we're
only gonna look at one thing what is the
model doing for it and essentially
trying that's our explanation for the
prediction okay the other thing we're
going to do is we're not going to look
at inside the model what's happening we
think there are too many numbers that
are going on so we're just going to
treat that as a complete black box just
some function that we give it an
instance it gives us some output and
there are lots of benefits for thinking
like this there are a lot of sort of
practical like for futures for
supporting future algorithms and things
like that but even very very sort of
pragmatically
you're not even tied to one way of
creating a model it could be in
scikit-learn it could be in pi torch
could be tensorflow doesn't matter in
fact you can also do these things for
models that you don't even have access
to it's hosted on some API or it gives
you as predictions you can still try to
explain those models and we have done
that quite a bit so that was one of the
restrictions we made so I'm not gonna go
into too much how we do this but
essentially what our idea is is not to
add more circles in this graph you're
not introducing new models what we want
to do is take any of these things and
move them to the right make them as
interpretable as possible all right so
how do we do this first version of what
we do is we essentially zoom in and
think of what's happening in the
locality
as a equation of a line as a linear
equation not going to go into details
but it has inherently what that means is
we are going to figure out what are the
important parts of the input and how
important are they relative to each
other
that's is inherently what a linear
equation means so let's look at an
example which is a little bit more fun
we'll go back to this case of I think
Christianity is the one true religion
which was predicted to be atheism by a
really accurate model and as an
explanation we are going to create two
columns one for atheism and one for
Christianity and we're going to find
parts of the input which is words in
this case we're going to find words that
are most important for each of them and
sort of list them out so for example the
most important word seems to be the word
Christianity and the model thinks that
in this instance it's an indicator that
this instance is about your sanity so
far so good Christians talk about
Christianity great the next important
word ends up being the word posting
which appears in the header and the
model thinks it's very indicative of
atheism this should be raising red flags
because we were thinking that the model
is looking at the text but it seems to
be looking at something in the header
the second most important word is the
word host which also appears in the
header and seems to be indicative of
atheism for the model and the fourth
most important word is the word eat of
Keith Richards who apparently the model
thinks is indicative of this text being
atheist and then there are some lesser
important words like the answer is
something I guess Christians talk about
a lot and is something that maybe it's
slightly indicative of atheism but in
but ultimately we now understand to some
degree what's going on the model is not
even looking at the text really except
for the word Christianity
it's only focusing on the words in the
header to figure out if it's indicative
of atheism or Christianity
and our software engineers as data
processing people we know what to do we
can just get rid of headers retain the
system or if we care about what's going
on in the header then maybe we are happy
with this model okay here's another
example this is one we did with an API
access which was Google's inception net
where we give our inception net a
strange image like this dog playing a
guitar as they tend to do and the model
actually thinks that this is I think an
electric guitar which maybe you know
it's a strange image it can get confused
but we can look at why it thinks it's an
electric guitar and this is what the
explanation looks like the gray part is
the part that the model is getting much
less about maybe it's not caring about
at all for this prediction for
predicting that this is an electric
guitar it's essentially looking at the
neck and the way that the person is
holding the guitar the person is
whatever it also thinks it's a coup
stick guitar with some slightly lower
probability and the reason is because of
the body of the guitar which is correct
I guess and then it also thinks there's
a Labrador in there somewhere and it
thinks there's a Labrador because of the
head and maybe it can see a part of the
leg down there it wasn't quite clear to
me but that's what the neural network is
looking at right and so now we have an
explanation for why the neural network
is looking at these different things
let's go back to this example where we
were predicting wolves and Huskies and
let's look at what the explanations look
like here here is what the explanation
looks like against every image I have
the explanation for why it predicted the
label it did the important stuff to look
at are these ones where it predicted
wolf you will see the explanations for
each of these images don't have the wolf
at all right don't have the animal at
all in there
all it has is the snow and this can
basically let us confirm the fact or
identify the fact if we didn't know this
already that we've built a great snow
detector but it's probably not doing
what it's supposed to be doing it's not
even
looking at the face not even looking at
the years as far as the volts are
concerned okay we have a slightly
different explanation as well called
anchors um I'm gonna go through this way
quickly but essentially what we are
trying to do here is find conditions
under which the input has the same
prediction yeah it's very difficult to
define abstractly so let me go through
examples here as well so for visual
question on string we have the question
what is the most - made of the answer
was banana the anchor in this case is
what do I have to keep in the question
so that the answer is the same and turns
out the what is highlighted there
because that's essentially the anchor
what that means is you can ask many
questions that start with what and for
this image the model is almost always
going to say banana and these are some
of the questions that we are sort of
automatically generated they're not
great but clearly the answer shouldn't
be banana for most of them here is
another one
how many bananas are in the picture
again the model gets it right says two
again the anchor is just the word many
so as long as you have many in the
question and the question looks a little
bit like the original one the answer is
always 2 so how many people are in this
picture it says - how many zebras on the
picture says - how many planes are in
the picture it says two clearly problem
but we also know from machine learning
point of view why it's happening now
turns out a lot of the count questions
like how many blah blah blah the answer
tends to be - that's how people are
asking questions when they're gathering
this data set when you're they're asking
questions about what is blah blah blah
in the picture they're usually asking
about what's the distinctive thing
object in this picture and often it ends
up being a banana or something that's
distinctive in some sense and so with
this we've basically talked about the
explanation stuff that we have done what
is nice about the stuff is it can work
for any model we've tried to be
completely model agnostic but
essentially we are there's some
limitations that we're trying to fix
it's essentially an approximation of
what the model is doing it's very useful
for detecting
dogs but only very indirectly if you sit
around and look at a bunch of
explanations maybe you'll get an idea
but it's a little bit indirect and so
we've also been working on how to
characterize problems with these models
or directly before I switch to detecting
bugs I do want to give a plug for this
library that we've been working with so
if you're doing NLP this is the library
you should definitely check out because
a bunch of other people have also been
using it and with this library you can
easily create models for your NLP tasks
what we've been doing is we've been
adding interpretability on top of the
existing functionality in this library
essentially to make any NLP model
generate these explanations and we have
varied many different algorithms on how
to generate these explanations and I
guess yeah some of them are listed there
so yeah you can there's also a live
online demo and you can play around with
it and produce the explanations sort of
real-time there's an example of
estimations but yeah they're very
colorful and they they're also useful
okay so that was explanations let me in
just of time quickly talk about how
we've been using adversarial attacks to
detect bugs they're going to be two
different styles of attacks we're going
to talk about here let's talk about the
first one which is semantic adversaries
where we're going to be trying to act as
a normal user we're not going to be like
the an adversarial user and try to see
what problems appear in the models
automatically so here's the idea we're
going to look at again one instance and
again you can't really see what's
happening so let's actually keep going
yeah let's talk about an example but
exactly essentially what we're trying to
do is find counter examples so if there
is one prediction that you're making
what needs to change for your prediction
to change and how that can be useful to
detect bugs with text the problem is
it's not clear how you can change text
right so if it says what type of road
sign is shown
well maybe you can move around a bunch
of characters and change the question
and that might change the output but
that's not very meaningful because if I
ask that question to a human they might
also be confused and essentially these
kind of questions are nonsense to users
and they're very unlikely to happen in
the real world if you use your deployer
model what we instead care about are
more meaningful changes and so we
introduced this notion of semantically
equivalent adversaries where the idea
was to make meaningful changes to the
text what that means is we're going to
take our original instance and keep the
meaning the same but still change the
text so here's an example what color is
the tray the answer was pink here is
sort of in decreasing order of how good
the questions are what color is the tray
with color replaced with the you
spelling which color is the tray what
color is it how color is the tray and of
course the last two are suspect like
they're probably not very good and so we
kind of find these things which can't we
try to make sure they mean the same
thing but also change the prediction in
fact for a model the answer was Green
for some reason for all of these
questions okay
so that's where we get these adversaries
from we can say what type of roadsign is
shown and we replace it with which and
the answer changes similarly how long
was the rain we add a new question mark
the answer changes and what is important
to know is that these adversaries or
whatever you want to call these are
pretty likely in the real world and
that's why we want to test against those
what's important is these are individual
instances so they're not really bugs by
themselves like just because one
question had this effect you know you
can't really call it a bug which is sort
of a long range larger scope and a thing
so instead what we do is we try to find
changes and this kind of works mostly
for only for NLP we try to find changes
that don't only change one instance and
flip it but change a pond
of instance and cause the model to react
weirdly essentially what we are trying
to find is other common patterns almost
like regular expression transformations
or simple transformations that cause the
model to misbehave so here's an example
of what that rule might look like if you
replace color with color with you there
are two things we are testing for one
thing we guarantee or almost guarantee
is that this will not change the meaning
of your instance almost never will this
change the meaning of the instance of
course it will change the meaning if you
say color is the American spelling of
color or something like that but that's
unlikely to happen and the other thing
we are saying is if you make this
transformation to your data your model
will change its prediction and it should
not and that's clearly a bug I hope you
all agree forgive if a model changes its
behavior based on adding a you that's a
bug and so that's what we automatically
find here are some examples from
question-answering these are what the
rules look like sometimes might not be
obvious what this is saying so let's
give you an example these are talking
about part of speeches so essentially
what this means is if we say what has
been cut has the question and replace it
with what's been cut the answer for the
single instance changes from cake to
pizza or who is holding the baby
it was woman who's holding the baby
turns out it's a man it doesn't always
happen but it happens often enough to be
a problem here's another one what noun
to which noun we saw an example of this
earlier what wrote sign to which wrote
sign we saw the color color as well and
here's another contraction one or some
adverb is where is the jet where is the
jet converts to where's the jet and the
answer changes right we have seen some
examples of these let's look at it
completely different task which is
sentiment analysis which lot some of you
might care about here's what one of the
state-of-the-art models does if you
replace movie with film the model
changes its prediction now on the
surface that maybe sounds ok
it's like film is something that's more
positive so clearly the output should
change what's more important here is
that that's all you're changing in a
review so if the review says yeah the
movie pretty much sucked which is a
negative review you change movie to film
it suddenly thinks it's a positive
review oh yeah this is not movie making
become this is not filmmaking becomes a
positive review because the other way
around also film to movie becomes
negative so even if you have a review
that says excellent film but you say
excellent movie this model thinks that's
a problem I'll give this film 10 out of
10 it's good but I'll give this movie 10
out of 10 changes the prediction and
there are some more like that right so
essentially these are things that could
happen naturally
somehow they weren't in our test set
somehow we didn't test for this and our
accuracy looked good and this doesn't
mean that accuracy is terrible but there
are these problems and we are trying to
automatically detect them all right for
the last set of examples that I will
quickly talk about it's stuff that we
call universal triggers Universal
adversary triggers this is stuff that
we've been doing very very recently sort
of hot off the presses so to say yeah
and this is stuff that we did in
collaboration with AI - that was
presented just last month just to give
you a warning that in this case we are
trying to break the system's as much as
possible
by being the worst adversaries as we can
or I guess the best out of three is
depending on how you define good or bad
adversaries but essentially we are
trying to see how bad can things get if
you're trying to deploy a system you
should know how bad can things get and
we're trying to sort of work with the
state-of-the-art research models in this
case here's the idea we are trying to
find these what we call triggers which
are short phrases that cause a specific
prediction to happen every time we add
it to any input okay let's break this
down a little bit here's
what a short phrase might look like
zoning tapping fiends doesn't mean
anything to me it does hopefully doesn't
mean anything to you and what what this
means is we can take the short phrase
and attach it to any input from a data
set so these are a bunch of positive
reviews this movie's amazing give him
the Oscar blah blah blah right and if
this face is attached to these reviews
the model starts thinking that these are
all negative reviews we found this
phrase automatically I'm not going to
talk about how but if we find this
phrase you attach it to your input all
the reviews become positive here are
some more slightly longer reviews that
were all positive we added these phrases
becomes negative and these phrase
becomes negative in terms of accuracy it
goes from an 86 percent accuracy model
to something that's twenty-nine percent
accurate here's another one which is
comedy comedy blue tarski again doesn't
mean anything to me it changes all the
negative ones to positive or almost all
the negative ones so positive your
accuracy goes to 23% essentially it's
50% of the ones are switched or
something like that okay
this also works across tasks so this is
an example for question answering again
this is actually strong language where
what we're looking at is question
answering system so here's something
that was strained on squad this is the
kind of thing you can imagine Google or
one of these is using if you say why did
he walk it looks at the text and says oh
he walked for exercise or for the second
case you say why did the University see
a drop in the applicants oh because of
crime in poverty in some region right
seems to be doing pretty well this is
the trigger that we add that says why
how because and then to kill American
people and the answer to almost every
Vie question ends up becoming to kill
American people we can change the phrase
we can change this phrase to whatever we
want
to see how bad can get but because of
the fact that we added why how because
and whatever phase we put that ends up
being the answer why did the university
see a drop in the applicants we had this
phrase somewhere in the text the answer
becomes to kill American people this is
question answering we can do this with
text generation also I don't know if you
heard about GPT - this was this crazy
language model that can talk like humans
and things like that
we try to see if we can get it to
generate a certain kind of language in
this case we were trying to see if we
can add a small phrase to gen have it
generate really racist text and turns
out that you can the stuff in green
which you can't quite read but it's
looks mostly garbage is something that
we add and then we let it continue
generating the text I'm not going to
read it out but clearly this is not the
kind of language you would want it to
generate just randomly here's another
sample with the same initial set of
tokens letting it generate text randomly
and it clearly you know it's stuff that
is racist right it's not even just like
we are generating these tokens and
letting it run free we can also say we
are going to give some input to try and
not generate racist stuff so again
there's some random token that we added
and then we say my mother says and then
continue generating and it says I'm
racist and she's right we say okay let's
forget about parents I love to see and
then we let it continue and it says
something that's at least offensive I
don't know if it's racist or not and
then the last time is last one is one of
my favorite pastimes and I was thinking
I don't know baseball or crochet or
something but it's it's not that alright
okay so with that I just want to end
just want to say we've been trying to
use many different strategies to find
problems and bugs and machine learning
systems here are all the papers we have
you should be able to find links to
and links to the code if so inclined I
just want to end with one takeaway which
is to test your machine learning
pipeline we know a lot about software
testing we know very little about
machine learning testing I think we are
in its infancy and we've been trying to
do some work in formalizing it but
essentially one thing you can do is to
take your original data look at what
it's originally predicting and then try
to put up your data and whatever makes
sense for what you're doing right for
NLP it makes sense to paraphrase and
things like that but whatever you're
doing just put a bit in some way and see
what the output is on this perturbation
strain and if your output is unexpected
and there's some pattern that holds in
general that's essentially what a bug is
and we should all be doing this if
you're doing machine learning I know I'm
over a little bit but thank you for your
time and these are all the collaborators
I'm happy to take questions if there are
time okay so I guess the question is
more generally can machine learning be
used for vetting people when they're
coming in the question is can it be and
should it be and those are two different
questions I don't know if it's been used
or not I wouldn't be surprised if it's
been used by certain countries um but it
should not be is it's definitely the
stance here partly because of these
problems you don't know what it's
looking at so there was this pretty
public article on Amazon that was using
some of these techniques to hire and
seems reasonable you look at employees
that were successful train some machine
learning system and the machine learning
system seemed to do okay but turns out
when people looked at what it was doing
it was essentially picking up words that
were unusually attached to female
applicants as cases that should not be
recruited right so if there was a you
know women's women in computer science
or something like that appeared in the
resume the model was just sort of
filtering them out
or if there was like some female college
right undergraduate college all-girls
College if that appeared in the resume
the model had a lower probability right
and essentially it was I guess
amplifying the existing bias in the
training data in a more worse way than
was originally the case possibly and
those kind of things can become much
worse if you try to use it at a national
security level so yeah and these systems
can also be gamed like I talked about so
you can easily add a phrase comedy
comedy but our ski and make sure you
always enter every country and that's
yeah I think you touched on this a
little bit and your answer just now but
let's take the Husky vs. wolf example
and this might be a naive question but
is it it picking up snow more just a
bias towards the pictures of wolves
having snow in it so if you added more
pictures of wolves that didn't have snow
in it it might pick up the in the
training data it might pick up some
other feature in that picture that
depicts a wolf instead of a husky that's
right yeah so I think the the problem is
if we know that snow is the problem then
we can go out and detect and gather more
data set the bigger problem is that
these time kind of things might be
happening in every machine learning
application right now we would have no
idea that that's happening right and
this is sort of like this is you know a
toy example that we created but pretty
much if you played around with machine
learning you would realize that oh I
forgot I added this column in my data
and clearly that's correlated with with
my label and yeah it'll catch upon it so
yeah great talk how did you generate
those adversarial attack terms that you
were showing that you know you could get
it to say from go from positive to
negative the natural ones or the the
very adversarial ones the adversarial
ones where I guess I can I mean do you
want to I guess the technical reason is
we essentially what we do is we look at
the
output and weed on a whole batch and we
try to find what are the things we can
add that would cause the probability to
go in a different way essentially using
the gradient information and doing some
kind of iterative search that's kind of
the short answer I guess yeah
and surprisingly fast to find those
things that if you have the model and
you can take the gradient it takes like
maybe ten minutes or something so yeah
is there any mathematical framework of
quantifying the the sensitivity of
models to these kind of perturbations
that's a good question I think people
are definitely trying to do that it's a
little bit easier in cases where your
data is completely continuous like
images for example so what you can do is
you can say okay my images are
continuous so there's a vector and we
can say any l2 distance or we can create
a ball around it in this high
dimensional space of pixels that
anything in this ball should have the
same prediction and whatever we can
define sensitivity that way it becomes a
lot more complicated when you have
structured inputs like text or tabular
data or and things like that where some
of them are discrete some of them are
text some of them are ordinal valued and
things like that it's very difficult to
define what a neighborhood is and if you
can't define a neighborhood sensitivity
is that little bit difficult to define
as well so yeah how does the kind of
sensitivity of ensemble methods compare
to like would they be more robust to
this sort of attack they can be but like
some of the I I didn't go into it let me
see if I can bring it up quickly yeah so
for this one for example these phrases
that we found they weren't actually
model specific as much as we thought so
even if you had in Samba love models
even if you had a completely different
model with a completely different
architecture trained on the same data
the same phrases transferred quite
effectively actually so in this case I
guess 63% were originally of the
generations were racist and that
she was the same when we tried with
completely different models that were
trained on the same data right so
somehow these even though these traces
look random they they tend to have
they're capturing something about the
training data which nothing in machine
learning so far is being able to fix in
some sense the student here not with me
but he's been doing some more latest
work on trying to see you know can we
even figure out what these phrases look
like for commercial systems that we
don't even have access to purely based
on a proxy or a surrogate model that we
have without knowing their training data
or anything like that and he's been
surprisingly successful in that as well
so yeah yeah let's have a round of
applause for dr. Sam using thank you
guys
[Applause]